there was a time when Hollywood might
have dared to duplicate this scene on a
painted backdrop or on the backlot of a
studio the more sophisticated high of
the modern moviegoer demands
authenticity of see so today when the
script of a major movie production says
Acapulco
presto tons of equipment an army of
experts and the galaxy of stars are
immediately whisked off to this
international playground once a
background of such exotic luxury has
been chosen every other aspect of the
production must match this high standard
and when Lana Turner is the star and her
role that of a willful heiress she must
of course dress the part to create the
spectacular clothes required for the
character of KITT the producers called
upon Academy award-winning designer
Edith Head not everyone knows that
clothes are screen tested as carefully
as performers these are wardrobe tests
never intended for public viewing the
comments are by Miss had herself his
Lana Turner the beautiful star of love
has many faces the spoiled beautiful
woman with all the money in the world
the woman who makes her own rules the
woman who lives for love and glamour
this incidentally is a look we use right
through the picture the the toga the
rather loose Greek look of clothes
and this is a group test of Lana Turner
Cliff Robertson Hugh O'Brian and
Stephanie powers for the picture stars
and the interesting thing is shows two
completely different types of women is
sophisticated woman of the world and the
unspoiled almost a genotype the almost
Angelou is portrayed by Stephanie powers
her clothes must subtly convey the
attraction of the other woman usually
thought of as a sophisticate the choices
can sometimes be hard
you see we make close work for scenes
after we test them we all sit around
like a like a jury and say well that
dress is a lovely dress I really like it
but don't you think that it's a little
too overboard a little too this a little
too that these slates are used to
identify the scene that follows this is
completely typical of Stephanie powers
it's green and white check gingham kind
of thing you wear that dries in about
two or three minutes another version of
Stephanie's beach outfit this is very
startling and done deliberately this is
a toga of fantastic stuff from from
France we brought this over particularly
do you be used in the picture over her
own slim dark bathing suit
you see in a scene where she is defiant
and and and and bitter she deliberately
puts on the the most flamboyant costumes
she can I don't know that she does it
consciously or not but in the picture
the way we dress her the colors the
flamboyant scene of her clothes health
express the defiance of ket who is
fighting the world almost single-handed
here is that costume on Lana as with her
co-star Cliff Robertson she listens to
the director map out the scene and here
the outfit works to create a sharp color
contrast with the vivid greens and blues
of the Acapulco scene she gives up she
gives a cocktail party so she
deliberately takes the format of what we
call play clothes and does them in in a
prince salad Lee covered with jewels it
amuses her to be different she's not
dreaming of conforming get ready for the
testing of the Bulls now visible in the
picture is an actually correct costume
as worn by anybody who is allowed to
participate in this sport this is
authentic down to the very last
buttonhole
I think this is typical of what I call
the look of kid who says this dress was
probably designed to wear in my villa in
outside of Rome but I've decided to wear
it tonight in Acapulco now this is
completely typical
of what I call the KITT look this is the
kind of costume that probably would be
worn as I said before in in a wonderful
villa in Italy it's daring it's very
extreme it's very European it is not
just a casual little set of pajamas that
you wear in in in in Acapulco in this
scene with Hugh O'Brien
notice how this costume actually works
with the scene
you see it was designed for movement
with comfortable neckline and armhole so
she can move it's what you call a
costume design deliberately for a
specific scene dramatic action always
speaks for itself yet is inevitably
heightened accented and subtly enhanced
for the talents of artists like Edith
Head creator of Lana Turner's
million-dollar wardrobe for love has
many faces
you